schön dass ihr bei uns seid willkommen
zu ZDF heute live einen Monat ist der
schlimmste Angriff in der Geschichte
Israels nun her am 7 Oktober drangen
hunderte Kämpfer der radikalislamischen
Hamas in israelisches Gebiet ein sie
verübten furchtbare grultaten an etwa
1400 Menschen und verschleppten mehr als
2 Geiseln der 7 oktober ist der Tag an
dem der Krieg begonnen hat seitdem
versucht Israel die Hamas im
Gazastreifen auszulöschen und es war
nicht klar was danach passieren soll bis
jetzt über Israels Plan für Gaza wollen
wir heute Abend sprechen mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler und nostexperten
Asim l difari wir schalten in die USA zu
unserem Korrespondenten Elm tevissen und
wir sprechen in Israel mit unserem
Reporter Stefan schlös schickt uns eure
Fragen und eure Kommentare einfach per
Chat oder per Mail ich gebe sie dann
gerne weiter wir starten jetzt mit
Stefan Schlösser in Tel Aviv hallo
Stefan der israelische Ministerpräsident
netanyo hat dem Fernsehsender ABC News
ein Interview gegeben und da hat er sich
jetzt zur Zukunft des gaserastreifens
geäußert lass uns kurz zusammen
reinhören was gesagt
hat wer nicht will dass sich der Weg von
Hamas fortsetzt also Israel wird für
eine unbestimmte Zeit die allgemeine
Verantwortung für die Sicherheit
haben denn wir haben gesehen was
passiert wenn wir sie nicht haben eine
Eruption von Hamas Terror in einem Maße
dass man sich nicht vorstellen
konnte Stefan wie ist das zu verstehen
Verantwortung für die Sicherheit
übernehmen
ja erst einmal muss man verstehen dass
es Israel vor allem darum geht die Hamas
auszuschalten die Hamas so zu schwächen
dass ein Angriff wie wir ihm am 7
Oktober dieses Jahres erlebt haben nicht
wieder möglich ist dass die hamasen
nicht noch einmal mit 100underten
Kämpfern n nahezu ungehindert nach
Israel eindringen kann und dort dieses
barbarische Massaker anrichten kann das
ist immer nach wie vor noch die erste
Prämisse aber natürlich muss es dann
nachher irgendein weiter ein weiter geh
wie das aussieht das ist noch vollkommen
unklar Netanyahu hat sich heute zum
ersten Mal in dieser Art geäußert
natürlich wollen Sie sicherstellen dass
es auch in Zukunft nicht wieder passiert
dass sich die Hamas nicht irgendwie
restrukturiert neu wieder aufbaut neue
Kämpfer rekrutiert und irgendwann dann
wieder zu den Waffen Greif und wieder
auf Israel wieder gegen die israelischen
Bürger loszieht das sicherzustellen das
ist nach wie vor die oberste Prämisse
wenn wir mal zurückdenken an 2005 es ist
ja noch es ist ja nicht so dass Israel
nie im Gazastreifen war bis 2005 war
Israel auch militärisch im Gazastreifen
präsent bis dahin gab es Siedlung in in
im Gazastreifen 21 jüdische Siedlungen
ungefähr 9000 Menschen diese Siedlungen
mussten immer aufwendig militärisch
geschützt werden mit Wachposten mit
Wachtürmen Kontrollposten und
Stacheldraht immer wieder gab es auch
schamützel immer wieder sind Menschen
dabei auch ums Leben gekommen und 2005
hat Israel dann in einer einseitigen
Aktion gesagt wir ziehen uns aus dem
Gaza Streifen zurück ähm alle Siedler
mussten Zwangs umgesiedelt werden viele
waren dagegen viele haben sich da
geweigert sie wurden aber dann Zwangs
umgesiedelt mussten den Gazastreifen
verlassen den Gazastreifen komplett
räumen seitdem ist Israel nicht mehr im
Gazastreifen präsent und das hatte ja
auch Gründe weil ihm einfach die
Sicherheit im Gazastreifen über die Zeit
nicht so wirklich von der Armee zu
gewährleisten war da hat sich ja viel
getan in den letzten Jahrzehnten
besonders seit der ersten und zweiten
intifadaer wurde es immer schwieriger
für Israelis sich im Gazastreifen zu
bewegen früher war das möglich da
konnten sich auch Israelis im
Gazastreifen frei bewegen zu diesem
Zeitpunkt dann aber nicht mehr es wurde
immer schwieriger die Bevölkung stand
auch nicht mehr dahinter dass immer
wieder auch israelische Soldaten
gestorben sind beim Einsatz in Gaza beim
Schutz eben der jüdischen Siedlungen da
gab es dann also den Plan der von Ariel
Charon damals durchgedrückt wurde alle
israelischen Siedler raus aus Gaza
seitdem gibt es dort keine Präsenz mehr
und wir sehen jetzt was es im Grunde
auch gebracht hat wozu es geführt hat
die Hamas konnte von da an schalten und
walten im Grunde im gaserstreifen wie
sie es wollte sie ist danach erst so
richtig erstärkt auch politisch erstärkt
konnte ihre Strukturen weiter aufbauen
und letztendlich hat auch das mit dazu
geführt weil sie ungehindert dort
agieren konnte dass sie am 7 oktober in
dieser Art und Weise zuschlagen konnte
Stefan wenn man bisher gefragt hat was
kommt nach dem Krieg dann kam von der
israelischen Regierung eigentlich immer
wieder jetzt muss erst die Hamas
zerstört werden und dann müss man
weitersehen ähm warum war hat sich
Netanyahu jetzt doch
geäußert nun ich will jetzt nicht so
weit gehen und sagen dass SE so
rausgerutscht er hat sich sicherlich was
dabei gedacht man muss aber auch sagen
so richtig konkret war das ja nun auch
nicht was er da jetzt von sich gegeben
hat es muss ja irgendwie einen
weitergeben nach einem möglichen Ende
desri des Krieges irgendwann wird es ja
soweit sein man muss sich aber auch
vergegenwärtigen wie die Situation in
der israelischen Regierung tatsächlich
ist Netanyahu regiert mit einigen
hartlinern zusammen da sind wir ich
Menschen dabei in der Regierung die
träumen davon dass Gaza zu Israel eines
Tages gehört und das ganze westjordan
Land noch am besten mit dazu die haben
eine eine Abneigung gegen die
Palästinenser ähnlich wie viele
Palästinenser es gegenüber den Israelis
haben und mit diesen Regierungsvertreter
muss nitanaho und seiner Regierung ja
auch irgendwie klar kommmen also das ist
durchaus durchaus auch ein Stück weit
politisch einfach zu verstehen wenn er
so eine Äußerung macht wenn man dagegen
z.B die Äußerung des
Verteidigungsministers Galland sich
anhört da klingt das dann schon etwa was
anders der hat z.B gesagt eines sei für
ihn auch klar nach einem Ende des
Krieges werde weder die Hamas noch
Israel in Gaza regieren da wird es
irgendeine andere Lösung geben müssen
wie die am Ende aussieht na ja darüber
diskutiert man im Grunde schon seit
Jahrzehnten das wird sicherlich nicht
einfach werden aber so ist das auch ein
Stück weit einzuordnen was nitanaho da
von sich gegeben hat und warum er das
auch jetzt von sich gegeben hat jetzt
haben die neuen Streit die israelischen
Streitkräfte ja schon neue Namen
gefunden Gaza Nord und Gaza Süd
ist das schon ein Hinweis auf eine
mögliche neue Ordnung im Gazastreifen
oder bzw es gibt ja auch eine Frage von
Jule wird Israel ganz Gaza einnehmen ist
das der
Plan also diese Einteilung in Nord und
Süd das würde ich jetzt erstmal nur
militärisch verstehen und nicht nicht um
da irgendwie Fakten zu schaffen um das
um den Gasastreifen irgendwie
aufzuteilen darum geht es nicht das ist
eine rein ein rein militärisches
Vorgehen im Moment es geht der
israelischen Armee darum ja die Hamas
auszuschalten die Hamas sitzt vor allem
im Norden im Norden ist Gaza Stadt dort
befindet sich auch der Großteil der
Menschen also in Friedenszeiten der
Großteil der Menschen lebt eben in
gazastadt also auch im Norden und
deshalb war es das Ziel der israelischen
Armee dort einen ja eine Barriere zu
bauen ein Korridor zu bauen von der
Grenze der israelischen Grenze zum
Gazastreifen bis zum Meer um in den
Norden erstmal militärisch abzutrennen
um auch das Agieren der Hamas zu
verhindern auch eine Flucht
möglicherweise von H Hamas Terroristen
zu verhindern um dann den bürtel enger
den den Kreis enger zu ziehen immer
weiter um gazastadt einzukreisen das ist
ja auch mittlerweile gelungen heute gab
es z.B auch Meldung die sind noch sehr
frisch dass die israelische Armee sogar
bis ins Herz der Stadt vorgedrungen sei
also bis ins Zentrum das sagte zumindest
auch der israelische
Verteidigungsminister Galland weitere
Meldung gibt es davon bisher noch nicht
von der israelischen Armee die sonst
immer sehr schnell alle Journalisten
über ihren telegramkanal informieren
haben wir da noch nicht aber der
Verteidigungsminister hat es eben gesagt
und der sollte es ja eigentlich auch
wissen und interessant war dabei noch er
hat gesagt dass der Führer der Hamas
sinwa in einem Bunker im Stadtzentrum
isoliert worden sein sollen ob das alles
so stimmt ob der wirklich noch da ist
oder ob der nicht schon längst über alle
Berge ist weil er dann durch
irgendwelche Tunnel
entkommen konnte das lst sich von hier
aus jetzt noch nicht sagen aber das wäre
natürlich ein wirklich wichtiger Schritt
für Israel wenn sie t wenn es ihn
tatsächlich gelingen würde sinba den
Führer der Hamas in ih zu werden oder
ihn sogar auszuschalten das wäre für sie
natürlich ein großer Erfolg also noch
mal ich würde das diese Teilung erstmal
rein militärisch sehen das ist
militärisches taktisches Vorgehen ja und
über die Lage im Zentrum von Gaza City
werdet ihr uns weiter auf dem laufenden
halten vielen dank Stefan Schlösser nach
telaviv ja und damit wollen wir dann
direkt Weitergehen zu Elma tevesson in
Washington hallo Elma grüß Dich ähm
Ministerpräsident hallo
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu hat in
diesem Interview mit ABC News ja auch
noch mal gesagt dass er längere
Feuerpausen ausschließt wie kommt diese
Haltung im Weißen Haus
an ja das kommt überhaupt nicht gut an
weil man in der US-Regierung natürlich
weiß dass man den Menschen im
Gazastreifen die Gelegenheit geben muss
eben tatsächlich sich in Sicherheit zu
bringen eher im Süden Gazas und dafür
sind zwei Dinge notwendig das eine eben
eine Feuerpause und zweitens dass es im
Süden dann auch sicherer ist als im
Norden und die USA weisen in
Hintergrundgesprächen mit uns hier auf
einzelne Fälle hin wo sie ganz gut
zeigen was da falsch läuft aus ihrer
Sicht also es gab ja zwei Luftangriffe
auf das Flüchtlingslager jabalia
innerhalb vom Gazastreifen und bei
diesen Luftangriffen hat Israel jeweils
2000 Pfund Bomben eingesetzt diese
Bomben haben eine so große Sprengkraft
dass sie eben nicht nur den Tunnel unter
diesen Plätzen zerstört haben sondern
dass dadurch auch größere Wohnkomplexe
eingestürzt sind und dadurch größere
Opfer unter Zivilisten verursacht wurden
das wurde bisher öffentlichen
Pressekonferenzen nicht gesagt aber in
Hintergrundgesprächen wird das als
Beispiel genommen dass man auch anders
vorgehen könnte und eigentlich auch
müsste z.B mit kleineren Bomben 250 pund
schwer präzisionsbomben die die USA
jetzt auch in großem Umfang an Israel
liefern wollen und wenn man das so
weitermacht mit den großen Bomben dann
wird das zu so vielen zivilen Opfern
führen dass eben die Unterstützung für
Israel immer und immer schwieriger wird
auch die Unterstützung durch die
US-Regierung weil jbeiden natürlich auch
innerhalb seiner eigenen Partei massiv
unter Druck gerät von denen die sagen
Israel geht zu weit in dem wie es im
Gazastreifen vorgeht dazu gibt's auch
einen Kommentar auf Facebook von Castro
er schreibt netanahus Politik ist
illegal und das wird auch noch ein
riesiges Nachspiel haben dem die Welt
nicht mehr lange zuschauen wird wie
Menschen zerbombt werden das ist die
Meinung von Castro jetzt hat netanah ja
auch angekündigt die Kontrolle im
Gazastreifen zu übernehmen darüber haben
wir eben gesprochen US-Präsident Biden
hat ja ganz klar gesagt das SE ein
großer
Fehler ja beiden meinte damit im Grunde
genommen eine langfristige Übernahme der
Sicherheit durch Israel denn das könnte
leicht zu dem geraten was man auf keinen
Fall will wenn Israel dauerhaft die
Sicherheit dort kontrolliert dann könnte
das Ganze wirklich den Eindruck am Ende
haben von einem großen Gefängnis in dem
die Menschen leben dürfen das aber
möglicher keine keine großen
Entwicklungschancen bietet für eine
Zukunft der Palästinenser in diesem
Gazastreifen deswegen versteht man hier
Netanyahu eher so dass er das für einen
Übergang meint weil man muss sicherlich
für einen Übergang eine Situation
schaffen in der Terroristen nicht
zurückkommen und nicht wieder erstarken
können im gazaastreifen ob das am Ende
Israel macht ob das andere tun ob die
Vereinten Nationen eine Rolle spielen
jemand muss die Sicherheit für einen
Übergang Gang sicherlich garantieren
bevor man langfristig für den
Gazastreifen auch eine Lösung finden
kannm die USA wollen eine zweiaaten
Lösung andere westliche Staaten wollen
das auch Außenministerin bbock hat ja
auch gesagt dass sie diese Möglichkeiten
jetzt auf dem G7 Treffen in Tokio noch
mal erörtern will ist diese Option durch
diese Ankündigung von Netanyahu jetzt
noch mal weiter in die Ferne
gerückt ja es ist sicherlich schwieriger
geworden eben weil diese Ankündigung so
Waage ist und dieser Eindruck entstehen
könnte er will dauerhaftter die
Sicherheit übernehmen ich glaube hier
wird immer mehr diskutiert dass die G7
beispielsweise und auch andere Staaten
eigentlich sich was vormachen wenn Sie
glauben dass es am Ende so einfach wäre
oder doch möglich wäre eine zwei
staatenlösung hinzubekommen und das
liegt einfach an den Gegebenheiten als
man die Hoffnung erzeugt hat äh mit dem
Abkommen von Oslo vor vielen Jahren in
den 90er Jahren da hatte man das Gefühl
das wäre noch machbar jetzt sind wir in
der Situation wo im westjordan Land in
der Westbank ja auch zahlreiche
Siedlungen entstanden sind wenn man also
eine Zweistaatenlösung wollte wie will
man sicherstellen dass es zwei
Staatsgebiete dann auch gibt also auch
ein Staatsgebiet für die Palästinenser
da müsste man möglicherweise auch die
Siedlungen im Westjordanland räumen
lassen also es wirkt hier ein Stück weit
illusorisch und es gibt noch ein großes
Problem auch für die G7 die sich ja den
Werten verpflichtet fühlen wir hören
hier bei den Vereinten Nationen
Vereinten Nationen in New York immer
stärker eben Äußerungen von Ländern wie
Brasilien oder Südafrika dem globalen
Süden die sagen ihr sagt uns immer das
was Russland da in der Ukraine macht das
ist eine Art von Zerstörung die nicht
sein darf einige von diesen Staaten
nehmen auch das Wort Völkermord in den
Mund und sagen dann gleichzeitig das was
wir sehen an Bildern aus der Ukraine von
Zerstörung wo eine Stadt wie mariopol
gewissermaßen im Erdboden gleich gemacht
wurden äh das gleicht mittlerweile
zumindest einigen Teilen äh des Gaza
Streifens wo eben durch diese massiven
Luftangriffe alles platt gemacht wurde
also MST ihr damit zweierlei Maß das ist
die Frage die eben sich auch an die G7
und an die Staaten die sich westlichen
Werten verpflichtet fühlen gerichtet
werden und das alles macht es
unglaublich schwierig gleichzeitig dann
eben bei Israel eine Veränderung des
Verhaltens im Vorgehen im Gazastreifen
hinzubekommen jetzt gelten die USA ja
als größte Schutzmacht Israels und
gleichzeitig lehnt Netanyahu ja zurzeit
vieles ab was Präsident und auusminister
blinken ihm vorschlagen wird das den
israelischen Ministerpräsidenten
möglicherweise dann auch bald
einholen na ja es gibt natürlich viele
die hier sagen ja dann können die USA ja
ihre Militärhilfe streichen und den
Rückhalt für Israel aufgeben aber
erstens wird das nicht passieren
zweitens ist die Militärhilfe etwa ein
Umfang von ja 3,6 bis 4 Milliarden
Dollar pro Jahr die tatsächlich aus den
USA kommen und letztlich das muss man
klar sagen Israel ist eine Atommacht und
sicherlich die stärkste Macht in dieser
Region mit und vor allen Dingen es ist
eine Demokratie es ist eigentlich
illusorisch dass man diese Demokratie
Israel im Stich lässt aus vielen Gründen
auch aus politischen Gründen in den USA
und deswegen ist dieses man kann Druck
ausüben auf Israel im Grunde genommen
eine Selbstüberschätzung so glauben das
mittlerweile viele hier die verkennt
dass es eben e um die Existenz dieses
Staates geht und das Netanyahu da
relativ viel Freiraum einräumen muss
weiterhin in den nächsten Wochen
allerdings das alles natürlich in der
Hoffnung dass absehbar Netanyahu und
seine Koalition die Macht verliert in
Israel dass die Menschen in Israel aus
ihrer Empörung heraus dass es überhaupt
soweit kommen konnte auch bereit sind
eine Opposition an die Macht zu wählen
die vielleicht bereit ist auch einen
friedlichen Weg eine Lösung mit den
Palästinensern zu
suchen ich schaue einmal im Chat da gibt
es eine Frage nach Washington warum
wurde das U-Boot verlegt wurde die
Gefahr für einen Flächenbrand
größer ja das U-Boot ist ein ganz klares
Signal natürlich auch an Iran wir haben
noch nie erlebt dass man solche
atomwaffenfähigen U-Boote dann auch im
Bild zu sehen bekommt wir sehen das Bild
wie es durch den Sueskanal fährt wir
wissen dass die zwei Flugzeugträger in
der Region sind also das klare Signal
haltet euch raus Iran macht das nicht zu
einem größeren Konflikt in dieser Region
das Signal wird ja als wichtig erachtet
gleichzeitig glaubt man auch eigentlich
hinter den Kulissen schon oder ist man
sogar überzeugt dass Iran es nicht wagen
wird auch nicht über hiszbolla einen
Krieg zu entfesseln weil man darf nicht
vergessen Israel ist auch eine Atommacht
und wäre in der Lage Atomwaffen
einzusetzen und auch der Iran und andere
Staaten in der Region haben keine kein
Interesse daran einen nuklearen Krieg in
dieser Region zu entfesseln jetzt war
Außenminister blinken ja am am
Wochenende in narost unterwegs
war viel viele diplomatische Gespräche
hat er geführt unter anderem ja auch mit
Abbas wie geht das weiter er kam ja nach
Hause und hatte relativ wenige
Ergebnisse ja in der Tat hatte man sich
hier natürlich mehr erhofft und deswegen
hat Joe Biden ja gestern der
US-Präsident mit Bibi netanahu noch
einmal gesprochen und hat eben darauf
gedrängt wohlmerklich kein enstillstand
sondern eben diese humanitären Pausen
diese Feuerpausen zu haben damit man den
Menschen Gelegenheit gibt sich in
Sicherheit zu bringen Joe Biden liegt
natürlich viel daran dass das ein Stück
weit vorankommt dass man hinhört in
Israel dass Netanyahu auch entsprechend
handelt man gibt ihm jetzt bessere
Werkzeuge an die Hand z.B eben diese
Bomben mit Springer geringerer
Sprengkraft diese 250 pundbomben aber
die US-Regierung ist auch innerhalb der
eigenen Politik hier ein Stück weit
unter Druck
wir stehen vor einem Wahljahr in den USA
und natürlich hat schon der linke Flügel
in der Demokratischen Partei sehr klar
signalisiert dass dies was da gerade
passiert massiv auch Joe Biden und den
Demokraten Schaden wird wenn er nicht in
der Lage ist Netanyahu davon zu
überzeugen dass man ein Stück weit
jedenfalls mehr Chancen für die
Zivilisten einräumen muss und auch
zurückhaltenender sein muss in der Art
des Vorgehens an dem wie gibt es kein
Zweifel ich glaube das muss allen klar
sein die US-Regierung
sagt eindeutig dass eben die Hamas
zerstört werden muss davon rückt man
auch hier nicht ab aber dies muss
geschehen in einer Art und Weise und
verbunden mit einer Zukunftsperspektive
für die Palästinenser dass eben Frieden
auf lange Sicht in der Region nicht
nicht komplett unmöglich wird lass uns
vielleicht noch mal kurz über die
Zukunftsperspektive sprechen da gibt es
auch noch eine Frage warum will kein
arabischer Staat Verantwortung für Gaza
übernehmen arbeiten die USA an einer
solchen
Lösung ja es gibt sehr intensive
Gespräche mit Ägypten aber auch mit
Saudi-Arabien und anderen Staaten aber
man ist im Grunde genommen nicht
interessiert daran die 2,3 Millionen
Palästinenser in den eigenen Ländern zu
haben das gilt allen voran für
Ägypten es ist im Grunde genommen eine
Vorstellung die ganz offenbar auf volle
Ablehnung trifft dass der Sinai
beispielsweise als eine Art Rückzugszone
oder sichere Zone dienen könnte weil man
eben hat dass die Ideologie der Hamas
die man nicht zerbomben kann sondern die
man durch zu viel Bomben möglicherweise
auch noch verstärkt dass diese Ideologie
halt übergreifen könnte in andere Länder
der Region und wenn man sich das genau
anguckt was die Hamas in den letzten
Tagen auch an Propaganda
verbreitet sie nimmt immer mehr das
Ausmaß in der Ideologie an wie al-Qaida
also im Grunde genommen mit einem
Anspruch der weit über die Region Israel
und anliegende Staaten hinausreicht eine
Art globalen Jihad sie fühlt sich im
Grunde genommen so ein Stück weit in
dieser Tradition und versucht die
Extremisten und Terroristen in anderen
Ländern auch aufzustacheln eben auch
Anschläge zu verüben und deswegen
erklärt sich warum die arabische Welt
wenig Interesse daran hat ähm so schnell
äh die Palästinenser den Palästinensern
zur Hilfe zu allen indem sie sie selber
in ihren Ländern aufnehmen Elma wir
danken dir sehr sehr herzlich für deine
Einschätzung mach's gut vielen Dank
tschüss
danke ja der Nahostkonflikt ist ein sehr
sehr alter Konflikt und er ist ein
wahnsinnig komplizierter Konflikt Nikola
Albrecht fasst jetzt die Zeit seit dem
sech tagekrieg zusammen man könnte
natürlich noch viel früher anfangen zu
erzählen aber wir steigen an dieser
Stelle ein weil dieser Krieg damals die
Region maßgeblich verändert
hat 1967 greift Israel mit einem
Präventivschlag mehrere arabische
Nachbarstaaten an und kommt ihnen so
zuvor Israel siegt überwältigend und
besetzt neben dem Westjordanland
Ostjerusalem den Golanhöhen und dem
Sinai auch den
Gazastreifen in den besetzten Gebieten
siedeln infolge immer mehr Juden laut UN
ein Verstoß gegen das
Völkerrecht 2005 räumt Israel den
Gazastreifen das Militär zieht ab und
die jüdischen Siedler müssen ihre
Wohnorte verlassen diekür Formel dafür
lautet Land für Frieden sie geht nicht
auf 2006 gewinnt die radikale Hamas die
Wahlen im Gazastreifen und reiß 2007 die
Macht gewaltsam an sich ihr Ziel Israel
vollständig vernichten und stattdessen
einen palästinensisch islamischen Staat
gründen damit grenzt sie sich auch von
der fatach ab der palästinensischen
Partei von Mahmud Abbas die das
Westjordanland regiert im Gegensatz zu
Hamas erkennt die fatach das
Existenzrecht Israels an und damit eine
mögliche
Zweistaatenlösung die
Schreckensherrschaft der Hamas trifft
auch die eigene Bevölkerung
Meinungsfreiheit gibt es nicht und die
Angriffe auf Israel nehmen zu Israels
Antwort Abriegelung und Blockade des
Gazastreifens seit 2005 gibt es immer
wieder schwere militärische
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen der Hamas
und Israel bis heute
lasst uns jetzt mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler Asim l diraui
sprechen guten Abend ja schönen guten
Abend wie kommt die Ankündigung von
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu jetzt
erstmal auf unbestimmte Zeit im
Gazastreifen zu bleiben denn in Israel
an das ist eine interessante und
wichtige Frage ich habe heute mit vielen
israelischen Kollegen gesprochen einige
darunter sind selbst l Mitglieder die
sagen auch wie ma tavisson aus
Washington man weiß nicht ob es ih
wieder unverendlich was irgendwas aus
dem Mund gerutscht ist oder aber er
probiert hat wirklich noch
sich an der Macht zu erhalten indem er
sagt ja ich bin wieder Mr Sicherheit und
ich werde den Gasastreifen
auf lange Zeit befriedigen
befrieden die Sache ist natürlich die
dass
in der israelische Militärpräsenz in
Gazastreifen auch unbeschränkt Zeit das
heißt eine erneute Besatzung für sehr
viel Unmut in Israel sorgen wird weil
die Israelis haben dort schon sehr viele
Soldaten äh in früheren Zeiten verloren
zudem löst das ganze natürlich äh
extreme Ängste bei Palästinensern und
anderen Arabern aus in dem Sinne dass
sie sagen Israel möchte Gaza doch dann
wieder dauerhaft behalten warum
soll man sich dann von von Hamas
abwenden also das Statement von
des israelischen Premierminister war
mehr als
wird auch von vielen Seiten so
bewertet ja für die Menschen
gazaastreifen wird aus die ihrer Sicht
oder würde aus ihrer Sicht dann wieder
eine Zeit der Besatzung beginnen ist das
dann nicht neuer Nährboden für die Hamas
fragt auch hier gibt diese Frage gibt's
auch hier im Chat wie wird in Zukunft
mit der palästinensischen Bevölkerung
umgegangen wird diese durch die
fortlaufende Bombardierung und die hohe
Zahl der Verluste nicht erst recht der
Hamas wieder zulau
glauben Sie dass diese Entwicklung
kommen wird natürlich unterhält her ma
Moment weitere Unterstützung durch die
große Anzahl von zivilen Toten aber
natürlich auch über diese Ankündigung
des israelischen
Premierministers dazu möchte ich noch
ergänzen dass viele Israelis hoffen dass
in schneller Machtwechsel in Israel
stattfindet viele Israelis hoffen dass
liberale Generäle und davon gibt es
größere Anzahl zum Teil sind wir auch
schon der liberale generelle in der
Regierung die Macht übernehmen und da
gibt es natürlich ganz viele Stimmen
bereits die unter diesen generellen die
sagen se erfahren sind wir müssen das
nachamas Mitdenken wir müssen den
Palästinenser eine Perspektive geben wir
müssen überlegen wer auch im Übergang
relativ schnell den gazastreichen
verwalten kann ist das die
palästinensische Autorität ist das
sollte das internationalisiert werden
kann man eventuell auch eine
Friedenstruppe der Arabischen Liga aber
vor allem der Vereinten Nationen hoffen
diese Debatten sind eigentlich jetzt
schon im Gange da ohne eine politische
Lösung sich dieser schreckliche Konflikt
überhaupt nicht mehr lösen kann mhm
jetzt weiß er niemand wann dieser Krieg
zu Ende sein wird aber soweit ist klar
die Ankündigung von Netanyahu steht im
Raum man wird Israel wird erstmal im
Gazastreifen bleiben und ih weiter
kontrollieren könnte es bedeuten dass
die Menschen die jetzt im gaserstreifen
vom Norden in den Süden geflohen sind
auf absehbare Zeit gar nicht mehr
zurückkehren können in den
Norden was heißt absehbare Zeit das kann
sich im Zeitspanne für von einigen
Monaten sicherlich halten langfristig
gesehen müssen diese Leute natürlich
wieder in den Norden zurückgehen ähm
Gaza City ist der größte Ort im
gazaastreifen ähm äh da leben rund eine
Millionen Menschen wenn ich mich nicht
ganz täusche und äh die Nachbarländer
das ist das einzige Nachbarland ist
gaserstreifen so gesagt Ägypten möchte
auf keinen Fall
eine größere Anzahl von Palästinenser
aufnehmen weil Ägypten auch fürchtet
dass die dann nie wieder
[Musik]
nach Gaza schrägich Palästina
zurückhören könnenm damit haben sie
schon die Frage aus
von Youtube von SGE beantwortet was ist
eigentlich mit Ägypten warum redet
keiner darüber dass sie keinen einzigen
Flüchtling aufnehmen es gibt noch eine
zweitere Frage warum will denn kein arab
arabischer Staat Verantwortung für Gaza
übernehmen es gibt ja auch das Szenario
dass eben eine Koalition von arabischen
Staaten die mit Israel verbündet sind
eben im Gazastreifen eingreifen oder bzw
die Kontrolle übernehmen oder die
Verwaltung wäre das denn ein denkbares
Szenario ich glaube es ist aber nur
denkbar wenn es dazu eindeutiges
unomandat gibt und dann werden was
werden es wahrscheinlich auch gemischte
Truppen gemischte tung mit Beteiligung
von arabischen Staaten aber natürlich
auch von ganz anderen Staaten auf der
Welt wo die arabischen Staaten bereit
sind zu helfen und das wurde immer
wieder groß
angekündigt ist finanziell den
Gazastreifen es gibt sogar die träume
davon oder die Vision den gazazil
Streifen zu einer Art Dubai der Levante
zu machen die Palestinenser sind gut
ausgebildet vor dem gaserstreifen das
vergisst man auch immer wieder liegen
große Öl und Gasfelder wo Ägypten Israel
und die Palästinenser schon über der
Ausbeutung gesprochen hatte ähm dieses
nachgaser heißt natürlich vor allen
Dingen auch dass ich die golfmonarchien
ähm für eine wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
dort einsetzen und äh Gaza äh zu einem
etwas ganz anderes machen als was es
heute ist
einem großen freilichtgefängnis und da
ist natürlich auch die israelische
Regierung gefragt und da gibt es aber
auch Stimmen die wirklich wie gesagt
eindeutig sagen ähm nach Hamas wenn
Hamas militärisch zerstört ist müssen
wir uns ganz mive Gedanken drüber machen
was wir in Gaza machen können um endlich
mal zu einer Friedensregelung mit den
Palästinensern zu kommen mhm dazu gibt's
noch eine Frage von Kali wie viele
Jahrzehnte wurde eine zweist
staatenlösung versucht gibt es noch eine
andere
Lösung also die zweist staatenlösung die
Idee entstand 1993 mit diesem so
hoffnungsvollen osloprozess und es gab
immer wieder Annäherungen es gab immer
wieder ein fast wirklichen Frieden und
dann haben Extremisten von beiden Seiten
äh den immer wieder zerstört
ähm
es gibt glaube ich keine Alternative zu
der Zweistaatenlösung da ein einstaat
ähm die jüdische Identität Israels
gefährden würde im Sinne dass die
palästinensische Demografie immer weiter
wächst dass irgendwann diesem Staat mehr
Palästinenser als Israelis leben würden
deshalb möchten auch die Israelis nicht
es wurden auch immer wieder über eine
konfederation gesprochen das heißt eine
lose Verbindung eben zwischen den
besetzten westjordan Gaza und Israel das
scheint auch sehr schwierig zu sein da
wie wie im Grunde würde das dann schon
auch wieder auf die zwei staatenlösung
herauslaufen das große die krcks im
Moment für die zwei staatenlösung ist
dass gerade unter dem jetzigen
israelischen Premierminister immens
viele neu Siedlungen im besetzten Wert
westjland Land gegründet worden und es
natürlich sehr schwer sein wird für eine
israelische Regierung zu sagen wir
müssen auch hier wieder Siedler
Umsiedlern und
Siedler Siedlung den Palästinensern
zurückgeben also ist ein sehr harariger
Prozess aber meiner Ansicht nach der
einzige realistische und vielleicht hat
ja dieser barische wegruf durch das
Hamas
Attentat in gewisser Weise Wirkung
gezeigt dass
z.B usamerikanische Regierung wieder
intensiv die zwei staten Lösung auf den
Tisch gebracht hat ma rosa hat noch mal
eine Nachfrage zu den Siedlern sie sagt
es wurde gesagt einer zwei Lösung stehen
die Siedlungen im Weg warum kann die
warum kann man die israelischen
Siedlungen nicht räumen lassen fragt sie
ja gut das würde natürlich
innenpolitischen Israel gerade un der
jetzigen Regierung für enormen
Widerstand
Widerstand sorgen
noch ist diese israelische Regierung an
der Macht man kann sich fragen wie lange
aber in dieser israelischen Regierung
sind
zum Teil rechtsextreme
sehr Rechte
die total äh in der Siedlerbewegung sind
und dies auf keinen Fall zulassen würden
und yatanao brauchte diese rechten
politischen Parteien um überhaupt an der
Macht zu bleiben wird es jetzt eine
liberale oder eine koalitionsreierung
eine Regierung der Mitte geben wo man
halt über das nachchamas den nachkrieg
nachdenkt könnte es sein dass einige
Siedlungen geräumt werden gerade
Siedlungen die sehr isoliert sind oder
gerade Siedlungen die quasi
palästinensische Städte voniner
abschneiden aber das steht noch in
weiter Sterne im Moment sind wir leider
in diesem sehr bedauerlichen Krieg
Sebastian schreibt eine dauerhafte
Besatzung ist nicht sinnvoll kostet
Menschenleben und Material und würde
Israel finanziell
Schwächen ja genau das ä das ist es auch
so und deshalb wurde auch ä
das Statements
des Premierministers heute in Israel so
so schlecht aufgenommen im Moment hat
die Israel durch
die Generalmobilmachung 400.000 Soldaten
400.000 Soldaten in einem 10 Millionen
Land
ind dem
auch Menschen einfach nicht zur Armee
gehen können das heißt z.B die
arabischen Israelis und auch die
orthodoxen Juden
nicht whrflächtig sind ist sind 400.000
Menschen enorm gerade in der
israelischen Armee und eine große
Belastung eine Besatzung Gasa ist eine
wirkliche besatzungsgasa das würde
ständig tausende von Truppen nach
Ansicht von militärspezialisten binden
und auch das ist natürlich ein sehr
hoher Preis und auch ein sehr
gefährlicher Preis den ein Großteil der
israelischen Gesellschaft natürlich
nicht zahlen möchte und deshalb dann auf
eine Lösung Lösung entweder dur
Übernahme der palästinensischen
Autorität in Gaza oder eben eine
Internationalisierung durch die UNO
hofftm vielleicht zum Schluss die Frage
also Netanyahu hat ja bis jetzt nicht
die politische Verantwortung für das
übernommen was am 7 Oktober passiert ist
mit ihm ist der Krieg in den
Gazastreifen gekommen
ist er der richtige Mann kann es mit ihm
dauerhaften Frieden geben in der Region
irgendwann
ähm das glauben vor allen Dingen auch
die Israelis nicht die die Israelis sich
für Frieden einsetzen würden das glauben
natürlich auch die Araber mittlerweile
nicht äh weil er man muss auch immer bed
denken die größte Mitschuld an äh an dem
im Versagen der israelischen Militärs an
diesen schrecklichen barbarischen der
diesen schrecklichen barbarischen
Anschlag der Hamas möglich gemacht wen
lag an yatanau selber er hat er hat
Hamas jahrelang geduldet um die
Palästinenser zu schwächen um sie zu
spalten er hat die Finanzierung von
Hamas also indirekt von Hamas also die
Finanzierung der palästenser
im im Gazastreifen durch Katar überwacht
geschehen lassen und da kann ich mir
kaum vorstellen dass heute jemand also
fast alle Israelis gehen davon aus dass
J nicht an der Macht bleibt und dass die
Frage gar nicht stellt ob mit diesem
Mann überhaupt eine Friedenslösung los
ist möglich ist dass sich vermutlich um
Wochen oder vielleicht um Monate handelt
bis eine neue israelische Regierung an
die Macht kommt bisher hat kein
israelischer Premierminister eine
militärische Niederlage oder ein eine
solcherheit
Sicherheitsgefahr als
als
als in der Politik überlebt Herr LD
fraui ich danke Ihnen sehr für das
Gespräch ich bedanke mich tschüss
bedanke mich danke damit wollen wir uns
für heute Abend verabschieden vielen
Dank für eure Fragen und Kommentare ZF
heute live war das zur Ankündigung von
israels Ministerpräsident Netanyahu den
Gazastreifen auf unbestimmte Zeit zu
kontrollieren macht's gut einen schönen
Abend bis bald
[Musik]
tschüss